alright alright
all right let's talk about source and
spirit
Jeremy you had some thoughts when we
were talking a little bit ago don't yeah
so one frame is that there's this
concept of source or that which creates
or that which generates which is general
across emptying like religious notions
of that which is worthy of worship so it
may be you know the Creator God it may
be the Sun which is the source of all of
the energy which powers our world it may
be nature which is the say a general
fund the water that we experience but
over and over and over again the things
that created us or the things that
generated us become the objects of
worship in part it's reasonable saying
the thing that created everything that I
am must be as or more powerful as I am
whether it's a mechanism or body of
resources or whatever and is also
capable of creating more things like me
or that would be even greater than me
and so there's a reverence for that
which is capable of creating and there's
a worthiness to the respect for that set
of se processes
you know like natural entities those
things those things have that kind of
power and so I understand like why empty
religious traditions well sort of like
respect the creator of you know
everything that exists that that accepts
to make
you have good a friend for source which
was all about nature right well I would
say that everything that you just said a
moment ago is the most important thing
in the world
period it's the understand source spirit
what nert what nourishes you yeah
what birthed you into the world this
whole process of evolution to get to
this point and every day the nourishment
that we get from the air the water food
and this ecosystem that we live on that
we are so disconnected from that we have
built the issues into social fabric that
we have today the self-dealing incentive
structures that we have today the mental
disorders that we have today and all of
those things are a direct reflection of
our inability to understand where we
came from so it is the most important
thing to understand the generator the
mother source or spirit what is more
important than that how can we be so II
go to school to think that there's
something more important than
understanding where we came from and
where we're going with this source and
spirit so there are few things there ok
what is this a sort of form of like
nativism or traditionalism which is easy
to get to if you say all things that are
deviations from where we came from are
basically like dangerous or could lead
to us being disconnected from where we
came from in a way that should be
avoided where I'd say that almost all
dramatic growth and change is going to
create a situation where say an evolved
organism that's used to one environment
is now in a very different environment
say because humans changed our
environment in umpteen fascinating ways
and now humans are evolved for an
environment that we are not living in
and so we're going to have all sorts of
instinctual reactions to things in this
new environment that are uncalled for
that are no longer useful and are also
going to be poorly adapted to umpteen
things that happen in that environment
because we fail to involve evolve in the
environment that we're living in and so
one answer might be oh well actually we
need to return to the environment that
we were made for that is the sort of
source of us and it feels opposed to the
a progression where there's some vision
for what kind of way of being is
possible and it certainly involves going
out in
- this sort of chaotic region where you
don't understand everything that's
happening where you know you end up say
creating so much affluence that some
huge fraction of the population doesn't
have to deal with problems on a
day-by-day basis that humans are
accustomed to dealing with and so feels
meaningless in the fate well in the face
of the absence of problems and so I
think there are umpteen issues that that
I come up existentially and our drivers
of you know like this sort of like
mental disorders that you're describing
which are a function of us haven't
created generators of all of the
resources that sustain us like whether
it's food and the Green Revolution
creating technologies that allowed us to
say plant substantially you know more
you know wheat and grain harvests that
like scales that were unbelievable we're
some tiny fraction of the population
that's not connecting to food whatsoever
that is actually disconnecting from food
a the whole idea of ubiquity of food on
every street corner anything you want
anytime convenience convenience drones
delivering it to you yeah it's all Optus
Kayson its distraction you don't even
know I don't even know how to [ __ ]
guard in our own food so I'm so
disconnected from Mother Earth's soil
systems the nutrients the care that has
to go into a seed for it to grow into a
tomato plant or a head of lettuce that I
have to go and give a piece of paper to
a store to buy that in exchange for what
I gave my time for that's right this
that process in itself is an obfuscation
of manipulation and a deception away
from source and spirit so all of the
things that you list and Steven Pinker
lists and the techno utopians list about
how everything's so [ __ ] great right
now that notion is actually cancerous
it's taking us away from the truth to
say that it's all so damn great because
we don't have smallpox measles and we
have vaccines and we have ubiquity and
food ubiquity and electricity there is
nuance to this there is nuance to this
the fact that you can now get access to
a portal that gives you access to all
knowledge that's ever been
created on so far on this thing called
the Internet is good and how about this
how about you have to graduate from
connection to spirit and source first
and then you can get access to the
computer why not that so yeah there's a
lot there you bring up a few like
worthwhile issues so one the fragility
that comes out of the systemization of
processes that used to be natural more
information used to be distributed
across people that is the information up
oh I know how to grow this plant and how
to eat it I know how to hunt down this
animal you know and how to prepare that
food that knowledge is lost in the face
of mechanisms that society created via
specialization and via the technological
is a ssin process right so I'm like I
now am hyper specialized and in order to
like learn how to do all of these old
things I have to master a set of
techniques that you know basically are
older feel antiquated that's a real
issue I have the sense that it's being
the right way to live or like the truth
that is you know all of the Wow
I don't know depends on where you want
to stop right like what amount of
technology is acceptable is like okay to
use Spears and okay use bows and arrows
I guess like all these can create like
minor forms of disconnection and one
thought is like in practice you identify
it as being the truth because it is the
environment lab in which we were
generated like it's our evolutionary
history but if we hadn't had some sort
of different source then that would be a
thing that was most sort of worth being
in touch laughs Jeremy let's take it
from a diving angle there's a different
way to approach this that will likely
drive a deeper sense of gratitude okay a
deeper sense of connection gratitude
towards whole spirit towards source
okay so sort of the abstract is very
different than the particular source
which is like you know nature and the
way that humans yeah you know operated
in nature sources everything sources all
that is spirit is all that is okay that
is what it is all that is and in this
realm in this physical realm that we
then from Big Bang until now this earth
generated around this star and this is
what we have has a home our home is on
fire because we are not connected the
house is on fire because we're not
connected to the house we're not
connected to let's let's let's let's do
this and let's do it through a gratitude
practice okay
you were you were wherever you were
prior to being birthed into the world
yeah okay and you were birthed into the
world the moment that you were birthed
into the world you were given the most
divine thing which is life
so with that being said how often do we
ground ourselves with the beauty of life
with how in all we are about how we are
alive every moment right now and how
we're breathing the air to nourish us
eating the food to nourish us the water
to nourish us how much gratitude do we
have to our parents that birthed us into
the world and their parents that birthed
them into the world
how much gratitude and connection do we
have to this house really how much how
much do you have you know how much think
about it reflect on it how much do you
have do you do you think that your
machine learning career Trump's your
connection to everything that I just
said yeah I guess I don't live in that
conceptional frame but I would say that
we as a species are a form of runaway
life that has disconnected a way that
every other form of life has sort of
failed to disconnect and we engineer our
environment in a way that no other
species tends to do and that creates
forms of disconnection which look like
us being in very different environments
than we grew in and also well you know
you talk about connection to to the
house and home the house at home was
created by us as a way to design an
environment in which we can more
effectively live that in bayson a house
in home was created by source spirit all
that is generated ostomy generated there
four billion years old this is not
something we made oh so when you say how
saying it's like took you to be
literally meaning like okay people live
in houses and they bought the house in a
house as an abstract thing which is yeah
which is earth which is our home okay
that is nice so our home is being
pillaged and it's inhospitable to us in
almost all places and it is our ability
to construct we're all workers of the
house that we live in
it's not inhospitable it's very bleak
the implica Arctic is like one so
they're umpteen places where humans were
not capable of living
till they develop the technology that
allowed them to construct like long-term
that's like like gardening and farming
is really unusual right like for the
most part for the vast majority of
civilization it was the most important
thing that we were doing well yeah and
then all the weights are still important
it's just now it's doable by a very
small fraction of the population with
like like caught it so now here's that
argument of oh we live in the best times
possible well actually in the past we
were more connected to where we came
from right and so this is a return to
the past oh maybe maybe maybe in this in
this scenario of tech utopians
we are run away species we are the human
race we broke away from all of those
silly plants and animals and insects and
source of spirit and we're heading
towards the moon and to Mars and to
colonizing the galaxy and that's exactly
why our engineering the new forms of
life which are more varied and dynamic
than could have been imagined otherwise
excellent so we can have we can have
hundreds of billions of people roaming
like we wrote life down more creativity
more longevity yeah that's right we
created new forms of thing that are not
life but are well and I'm teen ways
different and more interact reject er II
into the cosmos will be completely
different if we go with the current
level of maturity that we have versus if
we learn how to take care and steward
our own house yeah first it's the Meccan
then go into the cosmos right now it's a
bunch of kindergarteners that were given
flamethrowers that are trying to compete
to get into the cosmos versus if it was
a bunch of grandparents that actually
with grandparent ill wisdom that
actually knew how to steward a house and
then go and collaborate and compete in
making their way happening to the cosmos
I love the technology and science side
of things I love it but detecting
science in so many ways is disconnecting
us from taking care of the house and
there's seven point nine billion of us
that are disconnected from taking care
of the house yeah I think that there's
an extreme power there science of
technology has given us and wielded and
properly is like extremely likely to
like lead to the end of us that seems
right
happened to not to is like surprise to
previous civilizations you know that's
right
so I think wisdom is one way to attempt
to get around say like difficult
coordination problems but for the most
part we are like kindergarteners because
we are still using basically super
simplistic economic technology and it's
mediating our behavior like the way that
people prove themselves is by building
more and more powerful systems and if
that's the you know only way each
individual in this collective has to get
ahead they will like individually do
that thing and if there's some notion of
cooperation among all individuals where
so the collective it would be better to
do something else there's no person who
can independently change the say beliefs
of the collective and so you try to say
create a social movement around being
you know a source in a way that would
change the behavior of the collective
but even that mechanism you know the the
hope of say spreading some spiritual
belief like you know broadly and deeply
enough that some huge number of people
change their behavior
successfully like that ability is very
weak in us like we don't have that kind
of social technology and when it
succeeds it succeeds heuristically and
unintentionally and usually over the
course of many many centuries like a
tech ages for sitting say Christianity
to move from its inception out for like
you know most sort of religious it's
like you know seditions it takes ages
with them for them to propagate so I see
that that our say like social mechanisms
and I'm the medic mechanisms are still
very heuristic and out of our control
and what progress looks like either out
of their control cos that we're being
deceived we're gonna manipulate it I
don't think it's agentic
I think like nobody's capable of
controlling and that's part of the
problem where I I basically see there's
being many mechanisms that drive our
behavior but he's capable of controlling
the social fabric that we live in he has
built by people no more intelligent than
any normal person though no they didn't
build the social fabric they built the
mechanisms by which information is
propagated but they certainly didn't
like build the world views of the people
involved they like they affect the world
views of the people evolve dearly ever
since 10,000 years ago getting to this
point of everything from agriculture to
Industrial Revolution to information
technology age it has been happening
over and over again that we went from
having a kin tribe level Fitness where I
would love you and you would love me and
we would help each other evolve to the
highest level of fitness together so now
with 8 billion of us it's like you're a
stranger I'm a stranger I'm gonna self
deal for my own corrupt purposes and try
and get you manipulate you to believe
what I'm selling you as a materialistic
thing is worthwhile that's what we've
made an error with the global village is
about self dealing and not about an
interdependent interwoven stakeholder
process and so to be able to see that
the disconnection that entire process
came from our initial disconnection from
the you you pointed out there your
cultural revolution when you can
actually get food from your right let's
let's actually be more nuanced about
this let's do it when I am doing
something on a daily basis and if I get
a source of food from 10,000 years ago
from someone else that grew that food
that it was more connected to the growth
of that food it freed up my time to be
able to do other things you pointed that
out earlier yeah but someone who's
growing the food as part of understood
process of farming is much more
disconnected from the reality than the
person who say is like going out and
Hunter gathering you know I found this
berry here that berry there you go
farmer is like clearing off plots of
land typically and efficiently planting
the exact same crop in the set of crops
in the right order such that they sort
of like optimize the yield of those
crops so they can get as much food for
their you know city tribe or whatever
and that's also a massive agricultural
base there's days even prior to that
we're even see today's some indigenous
tribes just grow just enough food for
their indigenous tribe right and then
that's a complete
different connection processes and will
never support the number of people that
live on the planet so so here are the
things there's the nuance these are the
interesting things about time as well
where do you want to spend your time if
you are connected to source and spirit
if you are connected to where you come
from and the system living natural
system that you live in on a moment's
moment basis truly and honestly with
these real breath in breath out thank
you and again if you can follow
something like that like a paradigm like
that like the water thank you
hmm for the nourishment thank you
that if we can follow a paradigm like
that we can do whatever we want with our
time and it brings so much more maturity
to us to be able to solve these things
of how do we prosper moving forward to
devolve the errors are a direct
reflection in the mirror of our
disconnection from source yet Civet the
gratefulness especially is connective
and creates community and makes people
feel the appreciation
that's like essential to them feeling
like they're worth fulness there's this
like really deep desire for like who
love like you know both of the romantic
partner but like the love of like
everyone around you and from you to
everyone around you and so I think
almost every form of connection to
source whatever religious tradition it
would be tends to involve the creation
of strong communal bonds and that well
really as you know a human being is
super [ __ ] important and it's absence
you get the sort of mental degradation
that you expected to get and that's
where we live right now so everyone
thank you for watching I just want to
say do one thing one thing only connect
a source of spirit more often
consciously connect to the ecosystem
that gives you life and that supports
you and teach other people to do the
same go with them to the sacred grounds
of our planet and connect deeply to them
so thank you
cool
you can click stream where the mouse is
right now yep and then click recorder
right next to that